last week scientists in California
discovered a new earthquake fault line
that runs directly below Rodeo Drive and
Rodeo Drive is the high-end shopping
district in Beverly Hills
okay this is a big story got a lot of
attention think about it an earthquake
on Rodeo Drive would obviously have
major consequences for Beverly Hills I
was curious if any preparations were
being made so I reached out to one of
the geologists who discovered the fault
line he's with us I don't know why
you're looking over there this is via
satellite ladies and gentlemen what are
you doing what are you doing you know
man
anyway I think they got the hook-up now
he's with us via satellite please
welcome mark balerion let's get him in
here
hello mark
hello hello Conan now so you're a
geologist is that right yes I'm one of
the top geologists in Beverly Hills
you could go to Culver City or Glendale
for geology but you get what you pay for
okay right let's let's just be clear you
study rocks okay in Beverly Hills okay
all right so sir what happens if there's
an earthquake along Rodeo Drive what
happens disaster Rodeo Drive has lots of
stores and that means lots of shelves
here I'll show you this is just a
simulation but and this is just a mild
earthquake watch watch what happens with
just a mile cigarette look at all that
merchandise it has to be Rachelle dit
has to be refolded chaos right okay it's
a pain in the neck but that's a small
problem in an earthquake for you and me
but it shouldn't exist at all I mean
it's it's preventable
I mean it's preventable you're saying
yeah I mean that you can prevent an
earthquake that's crazy no that's what I
used to think but let me show you a
video the fault line in Beverly Hills is
basically a wrinkle in the Earth's crust
but you don't have to live with that
wrinkle the balerion method applies a
series of polymer injections into your
subduction zones and makes your fault
lines disappear the balerion method can
also increase the size and shape of the
Beverly Hills it's not about sexy it's
about confidence we can also use lasers
to remove unwanted brush from your
Valley and while you're here let us
bleach your Canyon freeway your asphalt
has never been whiter God's nook that
little the last one
everyone loves a bleached asphalt okay
Marc Marc Valero and everyone thank you
very much
you